before we go we like to say
we like to play a quick round truth or
dare
[Applause]
and today we have jasmine hi jasmine
he looks so great thank you all right
and now
you can choose a truth or a dare what's
it going to be drew okay hit us i would
want viola davis to play me if there was
ever a movie about my life
who would each of you
would want who each of you would like to
play in your life
that's such a great question um this is
hard i mean
i mean i'm just going to say what
everyone's thinking meryl streep right
yeah
it could work it could honestly work oh
it could i'm laughing because i'm like
she could do it yeah well i'll tell you
right now it's a roll of a lifetime
meryl congratulations your next oscar
i don't know who
i i always i want someone funny
because i like fighting i don't want
some heavy bird mm-hmm it's got to be
someone beautiful kind smart uh
funny silly well no i was yeah i was
just thinking i i kind of sound like i'd
be born for the role right
should we display each other yeah how
about that i'll play ross he'll play me
god that's such a good question
you know who could do it mary louise
parker
me too
yeah we do well she can do anything i
know um all right well gosh i'm i think
i think this one's going to haunt me all
day and night she's going to text me 2
a.m
maybe i'll get your number 2 jasmine
[Music]